but I want to talk about this morning  and it's the most difficult lecture that  I give because it is the goal is not to  convey a feeling or an impression but  you actually convey an idea and ideas  you needed gas or don't get it isn't  like you can halfway get how to factor  quadratic equation way they know how to  do it in its trivial or you don't know  how to do it and being conceivable what  happened to me was a series of the  channeling although I hate that word so  obnoxious I prefer maybe the word psycho  anyway a series of self amplifying  revelations springing from an interior  source that appeared to my best judgment  not to be me  you